Chad's the capitol hill autonomous zone
in Seattle how long will it be permitted
are the authorities trying to force
Trump to send in the military shouldn't
POTUS do something when locals won't
there's been a murder there already how
long can this go on yeah there was a
double shooting last night I think one
of the people died I don't know what the
state of the other one is how long can
this go on you know here's the problem
we've got a damned if you do damned if
you don't situation and I would say
damned if you do is better I cannot
allow this to happen
but I'm in the second person this is
actually our friend Holly math nerd
asking this the second question here are
the authorities trying to force Trump to
send in the military that certainly
gives him cover if it's you know I don't
remember who that mayor in Seattle is I
never do but Inslee the governor of
Washington another I'm gonna go ahead
and use your term decrepit clown
certainly wants cover he'd really rather
say that his mean parents told him he
had to then he asked you because he's
not gonna get a he's gonna lose votes if
he's the one to crack down on this even
though he shouldn't yeah should
absolutely it's absolutely 100% his job
to crack down on it but if he forces
Trump to do something and then he gets
to complain loudly about how Trump is
overstepping his authority even though
this thing needs to end then that
potentially frankly it's a it would
solve Inslee's immediate problem but it
probably also continues to feed to feed
Trump more more approval yep
I think there are a lot of games that
could be played for one thing in see has
aspirations for higher office or at
least he did until recently it's
possible that the idea is to get Trump
to do something that will be unpopular
in certain places and will shift votes
the Biden or something I am gonna push
back on your use of the reserved term
decrepit clown because Epping no he's
decrepit now and he's a clown but I was
he is a b-list decrepit true yeah
ballistic covered clown which is in some
ways an even harsher criticism
oh it's harsher yeah you know lest Akane
lift a decrepit clown
that's good yeah very good we don't like
this guy no well he let he hung us out
to dry
yes he did he absolutely hung us out to
dry there's the reason that we take such
a dim view of him yeah well also that
he's dim yeah
yes dim yeah you actually interacted
with him right your TED Talks on the
channel with them no wasn't TED talk it
was a talk at Evergreen on the basically
the Anthropocene and what to think about
it and he impressed me as a total
stuffed shirt that's the total stuffed
shirt and he gave a talk that was
completely empty and self congratulatory
about how Washington was leading the
world towards a green future all sorts
of nonsense yeah yeah he's got a lot of
wishy-washy stuff to say on climate
change a position that we have a lot of
thoughts on as well and I just wish that
we had better leaders on this front
how dare he be the guy that's going up
gonna be carrying that flag yep so
ballistic repet clan yeah excellent how
do we determine if the collateral damage
of the protests and/or local culture is
worth it we've been talking the Black
Panthers were necessary for MLK to be
more palatable what if all this works
it's really the second part of that is
not something I put together that the
the connection I what you know one thing
that immediately jumps out at me here is
we don't have I mean we do have many
people who could be doing the work of
MLK but what we have at the moment is if
this if this is right this analogy is
right the equivalent of the Black
Panthers taking over and becoming the
dominant voice and it's not that they're
covering for something else like who are
the voices that are actually making
making the correct arguments for police
reform and you know lingering effects of
racism in the courts and such so I'm a
little troubled by this question because
the movement itself cannot mature into
something meaningful it is too convinced
of wrong things and what we are seeing
in the horizontal nosov it's exercises
of power the fact that it is toppling
institutions from with
and causing them to start
[Music]
distributing kool-aid to the outside
world that that phenomenon can't be
turned off the people inside those
institutions are confused and they're
not going to become unconvincing has to
rein in their confusion even if
ultimately as I've been advocating as
loudly as I can even if we deal with the
fundamental I'm I can't even say
inequity anymore because they've robbed
us of the term equity but even if the
fundamental problems were to be
addressed the the force is not this mind
numbing
nihilist destructive destroyed George
Washington nonsense
yeah you know and go after you know we
didn't end up talking about black lives
matter today maybe we'll do so on
Tuesday but you know some of the some of
the principles that they have on their
website around things like going after
the nuclear family as if it's a
constructed Western artifact you know
it's suggested whoever wrote that and
you ever let that go up has never gone
anywhere else talked to anyone else
learned history thought about any other
species anything you do that the family
is a construct that needs to be
destroyed
is actually a far more egregious
position than that all of the founding
fathers need to be canceled and and that
does seem to be what is being argued so
you know if that's one of the founding
principles here there's no good that can
come of it this movement as currently
constituted has no capacity to build and
actually the failure of the Chas which
is now the chop oh yeah
yes stand for Capitol Hill occupied
protest which doesn't even make sense
and then I'd protest Capitol Hill there
at chop could mean two things they can't
even get an acronym so they've got an
acronym that they are in fighting about
what it means right as people are being
killed yeah you want to put up that
webpage that's a Wikipedia page yeah
yeah
no capitol hill autonomous Sun yeah we
can't that's too small for us to oh
there it is yep it's also known as free
Capitol Hill and referred to as the
Capitol Hill organized protest and the
Capitol Hill occupied protest so if you
can't get your acronym straight so that
there are four terms running around for
exactly the same location and people are
being shot there's a pretty good chance
you don't really know how civilization
works and you're not the people to whom
it should be handed over this is this is
one of the things that happens when you
abandon the idea of leaders and this is
you know what what you've talked about
now on Joe Rogan and elsewhere and and
here this is what you saw what we saw
but do you saw more intimately with
occupy yeah that from the beginning it
was understood to be leaderless by
intention but the leader lessness was of
course gamed as it will always will be
as it always will be
so the final answer to that question
though is the movement cannot build the
movement however is scaring the crap out
of people so that they may be ready to
hear something that many could not hear
before and so to the extent that a bunch
of us are scrambling trying to point out
what the actual meaning of this moment
is and what needs to happen in order to
prevent us from sliding into a Maoist
takeover which to which we seem to be
headed that might open the door to
positive change and I'm loathe to give
credit to people who have threatened the
foundations of civilization in order to
move things but if we get there I guess
we can fight about how to how to address
the history this one is a two-part
question you've consistently described
elements of the protest as Maoist are
you aware that Steve ban and other and
others like him are used in the exact
same term second question in describing
protests as Maoist what incentive do
protesters and sympathizers have to
listen with an open mind to your
perspective how does it encourage
rational engagement our compromise so to
the first question I didn't know that
Steve Bannon and others like him
whatever that means exactly you're using
the exact same term and I'm no fan of
Steve Bannon but it doesn't matter it
does it doesn't matter if people who are
actually you know hate
I'm not saying that Steve Bannon is but
you know it doesn't matter if people who
are completely hateful come to the same
conclusion that you are that does not
render your conclusion false well and
you know if you're going to behave in a
Maoist fashion and the problem is we're
left grasping for alternatives it's so
Maoist it's so you know struggle
sessions have emerged we need to invent
some other personal euphemism that Steve
Bannon won't have heard of in order that
he won't settle on the same formulation
it's not you know history history
doesn't repeat itself but if it were us
right so you know do we have a red guard
not exactly you know is it is it exactly
to a pert you know to it to a detail
struggle sessions no but you know of all
of the possible comparisons and we we
listed a few of them actually in our
Washington Examiner article in 2017
after evergreen blew up the weird that
you know the 4500 words the longest
piece that we've written about what
happened at Evergreen far from complete
but you know we started I think by
saying you know is it is this that you
come up the Jacobins is this the French
Revolution is the Brownshirts is this
the Cultural Revolution not exactly any
of them but a little bit of each and
really the closest one that I've seen
and you neither of us are historians and
I'm sure we're missing a lot of detail
here but is the Cultural Revolution but
this looks like China in the 60s and to
the extent that there's a question about
does this lead to openness on the part
of those behaving this way to hearing
what we have to say my hope actually I
don't think most of them know anything
about the Red Guard they don't know
anything about the Great Leap Forward
the Cultural Revolution and to the
extent that they start hearing an
accusation that they can't feel because
they don't know anything about it maybe
they'll look it up and they will notice
their own behavior matching this thing
and they'll think that's odd mm-hmm I
don't want to live that way why am i
behaving in this fashion now I'm not
expecting that to wash over them but to
the extent that one could plant a seed
that got them to look up something
useful the parallel is too close to be
ignored and you can't really I mean we
get into this too with the you know the
lab leak hypothesis
Trump has politicized the idea that
maybe this came from
the Institute of virality what are we to
do not talk about it because Trump has
some thing that overlaps sort of with
what we're saying this is anti science
yes is this is dismissing ideas on the
basis that someone else who believes it
is is hateful or antithetical to the
cause that you believe and this is this
is explicitly anti-scientific I will say
that in the last couple of weeks I asked
some friends for their suggestions as to
how to learn more about the Cultural
Revolution because I read a bit decades
ago when I was in high school in college
and really haven't gone back recently so
as you as you know I've got this pile of
books now waiting for me to dig in and
you know i I've poked in a few places
and it's hard not to act as a
verification ax straight it's hard not
to just see the confirming examples and
I'm trying to do the falsification a
thing that we always try to do but so
far and I'm not very far into any of
them I am I am more affirmed in my sense
that this looks more like China in the
sixties than any of these other examples
that we have yeah and I think it's it's
good that you've got the books and I
think we know they're not going to burn
themselves so certainly hope not
self-immolating books great that's a
thing yay
[Music]